[Música]
salud en directo América de France 24
más Romero sala ya estaba con nosotros
en el estudio marra muy buen día un
gusto tenerla con nosotros vamos a
hablar del VIH y el estigma que pesa
sobre las personas contagiadas en
Colombia cómo está Raúl Así es lo
hacemos con motivo de un estudio que se
publicó esta semana por la organización
en territorio de la mano con el
Ministerio de salud y también
organizaciones civiles que arroja datos
tan útiles como alarmantes pongamos unos
ejemplos no por ejemplo estamos hablando
de que las personas que viven con VIH en
Colombia al menos las que fueron
encuestadas unas 900 personas de ellas
del 15,4% habían recibido agresiones
virtuales en el año 2021 Por cierto en
Bogotá en la capital la cifra rozaba el
30% es decir estamos hablando de pues
tres de cada diez personas y además
también el 24 casi un cuarto de las
personas atribuían agresiones físicas
que habían recibido tanto a pues al VIH
como único o como uno de los múltiples
factores por las cuales habían recibido
estas agresiones son cifras totalmente
inadmisibles que muestran que a veces
este estigma en el que hablamos si tiene
que ver con murmuros en la espalda con
hablar con discriminación en el trabajo
pero que luego todo esto se traduce de
una forma muy real y muy directa sobre
la vida de estas personas que reciben
estas violencias por parte del entorno
Quiénes son los que ejercen ese tipo de
discriminación más bueno tenemos que
empezar por aceptar que probablemente
todos tenemos algo de estigma
internalizado no como pasa con muchas
otras discriminaciones entonces
empecemos por ahí pero la verdad es que
eso es especialmente grave cuando se
trata de profesionales de la salud que
tienen la responsabilidad de cuidarnos a
todos y de cuidar de las personas
contagiadas de VIH esto es una de las
cosas que ponía de relevancia Pues el
informe que también nos contaba Carlos
González uno de los coordinadores de
esta investigación escuchémoslo las
personas del sector salud increíblemente
le pasa lo que le pasa a población
general hay un desconocimiento frente al
VIH O sea
las personas
aún no conocen o no reconocen Cuáles son
las reales formas de transmisión del VIH
se tiene todavía mucha desinformación o
sea
se tenían antes
no lo vamos a repetir las veces que haga
falta el VIH se transmite a través de
ciertos líquidos corporales por ejemplo
la sangre también el semen también las
secreciones rectales o vaginales esto
sin contar por ejemplo leche materna
pues las formas de contagio de madres a
hijos no Y para que el VIH se contagia
uno de estos líquidos contaminados
contagiados de una persona tiene que
entrar en contacto con otro de la
persona que se va a contagiar esto Cómo
puede pasar por ejemplo usando una aguja
contaminada o entre relaciones sexuales
pues sin protección no pero el VIH lo
vamos a decir como decíamos las veces
que falta que haga falta no se transmite
por la saliva por ejemplo no se
transmite tocando a una persona que esté
contagiada no va a pasar nada si
comparten habitación si beben agua del
mismo vaso si les cocinan no Y además
toda esta información es muy accesible
hoy en día así que no tenemos excusa y
menos Los profesionales de la salud para
que se siga aislando a veces o
discriminando a las personas con VIH en
su vida cotidiana a informarnos sobre
este tema Mari y las consecuencias que
puede tener el peso de esta
discriminación sobre las personas con
claro hablamos de un Rango muy amplio No
desde a veces como una autoestima una
discriminación internalizada a raíz de
recibir violencia y pues discriminación
externa hasta perder un trabajo A veces
o quedarse aislado en el ámbito laboral
pero Carlos González nos hablaba de algo
también muy particular de qué le pasa
precisamente nos contaba una persona
cuando es diagnosticada con VIH
no voy a tener la misma red de apoyo
Porque es que mi red de apoyo no lo sabe
Y si le digo entonces tengo el temor de
que me rechacen y lo poco que tenía de
red de apoyo Este desaparezca Entonces
es importante
poder entender que
este este fenómeno del estima y la
discriminación va si no lo sabemos
manejar si no hay un acompañamiento de
las personas puede crearle un rechazo
puede crearle un aislamiento puede crear
depresión y algunas alteraciones que
afectan la salud mental de la persona y
es necesario poder hacer digamos un
abordaje mucho más integral
nos mencionaba esta red de apoyo y para
eso también es importante ver pues Cuál
es la confianza de las personas
diagnosticadas para contar que están
contagiados de VIH para compartir su
diagnóstico no veíamos que por ejemplo
solo el 24 o sea un cuarto de los
familiares adultos por ejemplo los
padres de estas personas no sabían que
sus hijos estaban contagiados de VIH en
las amistades hasta un 42% en una de las
partes de la red de apoyo precisamente
más importante para ayudar a transitar
el diagnóstico y todo lo que viene
asociado a él y luego en escenarios
comunitarios Como por ejemplo escenarios
laborales la mitad más de la mitad de
las personas no se atrevían a compartir
su diagnóstico precisamente no para
hablar pues como decíamos de ese miedo
nos dice no nos muestra ese miedo que
tiene la gente a compartir este
diagnóstico en escenarios por ejemplo
laborales qué podemos hacer nosotros más
ante la discriminación pues Empezando
por informar como hace el estudio como
estamos haciendo nosotros en este
momento no repetir toda esta información
que ya tenemos después de décadas de
investigación no estamos en el mismo
momento momento en el que se descubrió
el virus o que empezó a propagarse no
luego también entender bien los riesgos
de contagio entender que hay grupos de
riesgo por supuesto no que que pueden
estar más expuestos pero que el VIH
puede afectar a todo el mundo por igual
y también pues pedir rendición de
cuentas a quienes deben cuidar de
nuestra salud No a la también a escuchar
a las personas contagiadas a las
personas que viven con VIH que necesitan
y por ejemplo en Colombia No De donde
era este estudio un país muy rural donde
hay casos de personas que han tenido que
salir de sus comunidades migrar a las
ciudades uno por la discriminación y dos
para poder acceder a tratamientos pues
sobre todo intentar que todos estos
tratamientos toda esta información y
todo este cuidado también llegue a todas
las personas que lo necesitan mar como
siempre Muchísimas gracias por toda la
información Gracias